bottom right
corner slow it all down
Savannah see
it say the word you know what to
do God
God family
family
survival it's Al me big cat just wanted
us to pay a little
visit
leave them
alone they're under the impression that
you're in big cat's dead that youo I
took a loan on my
place how much trouble are we
in I'll handle
it I got a big cat
problem the damn queen of OD and
C I'm not sure what I could do about
that if you're going to survive in these
Hills you need to get used to a little
blood why are you putting the screws on
me and my family now I got good strong
boys they don't have your
gifts I thought I'd give you a chance to
work off a debt so I don't put your
niece and brother-in-law and a
whole three jobs to pay off a debt three
jobs and I'm
done it don't matter what you do
I say when it's
over father get me the
courage to kill these bastards he
Me You Ready for War I never needed
something more in my
life take him out make a show of it all
right boys
forgot let's go k for
family
survival